now we are
okay good morning members
um this is the licensing premises review
for crafty casts at 33 eastwood road
um as you will be aware this morning um
our
democratic services officer sony was
notified that the third member
of the subcommittee unfortunately is
not able to attend um today's meeting
due to ill health
um that's somewhat unfortunate but given
the late
notice it's not been possible to arrange
for a further member
to attend and to properly prepare
under section 9 subsection 1 of the
licensing act 2003
a licensing committee may establish one
or more
subcommittees consisting of three
members of the committee
for the purpose of these hearings um as
such um with only two members you were
not for it for the purposes
of the hearing under regulation
of the licensing hearing regulations
um you may adjourn a hearing to a
specified date
or arrange for a hearing to be held on
specified additional dates
where it considers this to be necessary
for the authorities consideration of any
representations or notice
made by a party i would suggest
members that it would be right in
circumstances for you
to adjourn this hearing to a specified
date
i understand that the applicant
interested parties and relevant
authorities have been notified of this
and the date has been suggested for the
4th of november but in the circumstances
that would be my recommendation to the
two of you
by agreement that you adjourn to the 4th
of november
and if it is in the public interest to
do so
and comply with the licensing act
hearing the meeting but it remembers if
you could perhaps confirm whether you
would agree to that cause of action
yeah that's agreed
sony will will the meeting be held at
the same time on the fourth of november
can we confirm
those that date and the timings
um to be adjourned too
yes um we we we hope to adjourn the
hearing
uh to the 4th of november at 10
45 a.m
counselor if councillor carter and
perhaps you could just confirm that
you were in agreement with council
america on that time as well
yeah i'm in agreement with councillor
merrick thank you
thank you and this newton can be
adjourned
thank you